jose está entrenando para un concurso de
comer hot docs la persona que coma más
hot docs en 10 minutos será el ganador
si eres el número de hot docs que jose
puede comer en un minuto y n es el
número total de hot docs que él come en
el concurso podemos escribir la
siguiente ecuación tiene es el número de
cotos que come en el concurso y lo
dividimos entre 10 minutos que es lo que
dure el concurso eso nos va a dar r el
número de hot docs que en promedio jo se
come en un minuto dijo se puede comer
seis y cuatro quintos hot docs en un
minuto aquí nos están dando el valor de
r cuántos code ox puede comer durante
los 10 minutos del concurso es decir nos
están pidiendo el valor de n que tenemos
aquí así es que n dividido entre 10 es
el valor de r que es 6 enteros cuatro
quintos el número de hot docs que puede
comer por minuto hay dos maneras de
atacar esto una manera es bueno si
tenemos que este es el número de hot
docs que puede comer por minuto y el
concurso dura 10 minutos pues por 10
este número entonces en 10 minutos se
puede comer 6 por 10 64 quintos por 10 8
él podría comer 68 hot docs básicamente
estamos multiplicando por 10 ambos lados
de la ecuación otra manera resolver esto
es probar los números va a tomar más
tiempo pero nos da una idea de cómo se
relacionan los números a través de esta
ecuación sobre todo que aquí nos están
dando una serie de números con los
cuales podemos probar por supuesto la
mejor opción es trabajar lógicamente
esto para encontrar el número que si
dividimos entre 10 nos da 6 enteros
cuatro quintos y así encontrar como lo
hemos hecho que el número es 68 o si lo
prefieres puedes probar estos distintos
números
65 dividido entre 10 y 6.5 ese no es el
valor de que tenemos 56 dividido entre
10 es 5.6 que tampoco corresponde 68
dividido entre 10 es 6.8 o 6 enteros 8
decimos que simplificando es 6 enteros
cuatro quintos así encontraríamos este
valor de 68 y finalmente probamos 45
dividido entre 10 es 4.5 corresponde al
valor de er en fin ambos métodos son
válidos lo importante aquí es que
entiendas cómo funciona esta relación y
cómo es que interactúan estas variables